what is up everybody welcome to another
python matpot lib live updating charts
tutorial
as i said i wanted to take this current
example that we have that's just
graphing data from the sample text
and while that is graphing it live
that sample text is pretty boring data
to graph live so
now what i want to do is step up those
charts from the previous
python and charting tutorial series and
we're going to make those charts
even better now i know you were thinking
that you thought that wasn't even
possible
but here we go live charts so the first
thing we need to do
uh with those live charts is uh change
how we're reading the data
right so if we come down and let me
bring over the
api here if you recall um
we were reading one day open high low
close or in some cases it was more than
one day like here it's three day
open high low close since this example
is 10 years
um but it is in
you know years the year 2003
the month and the day right here but if
we
uh bring this down to more like let's
say one
day and load that up and all of a sudden
it's changed right it's not
from year 13 you know 83
month 500 you know now this is in unix
time
and then you've got the actually i guess
yeah it's close high
low open volume but anyway then you've
got the exact same data
right and so really the only thing we
need to change is this
right here and because also
if you guys recall we're using
the moving averages and we're doing a
macd and some other
stuff and like both of those like a
moving average
and the macd you don't really have to
change anything there because
the those are using like
it's like a it's a time frame right so
even even on the one
day right the one day was just happened
to be each data point was a one day
and in this scenario each data point is
a minute
so either way you're looking at in this
case it would be you know if we're using
20 and 200 then it would be 20 minutes
200 minutes
uh if you're using the macd since it's
26 12 and 9
26 minutes 12 minutes 9 minutes versus
26 days
and so on so we don't have to edit any
of that the only thing we need to do
is fix up the conversion of this unix
timestamp
and uh well that might sound a little
bit confusing it's actually it's not too
bad
we'll be able to do it so what i'm going
to do is just take out we're going to
leave live graphs for now and let me
pull
up i'm just going to move it over to the
side and we're going to pull up the
old version of the
the analysis so i'll show you that in a
second
okay so this is the end of the
python charting uh tutorial series let's
run it make sure everything's tied
uh correctly so as you recall stock to
plot
and then let's just say we want to plot
apple pulls apple
and pops up a nice beautiful chart
for apple and now our goal is to make
this exact same chart
um work with intra-day data not only
intra-day data
but also uh we're going to make this
update
live which is gonna be pretty awesome
you'll see this updating live
so let me close out of this and although
just keep in mind it's one minute
live data but if you had other live data
you could pass it through as well
so this is what we want to edit now uh
we don't need this variable here
and let me go through here real quick
and delete any comments that we don't
need
all right so to fix this what we all we
really have to do is come down here
and here's where we're pulling the stock
and you can see
just for just for the record i try to
make the text as big as possible on
these little interpreters
so and make the window big enough so it
can be really nicely viewed in hd
but sometimes obviously the lines get
too long
and so you just have to bear with me
there if anybody ever wants me to like
post the full line just ask and i can
post any of these like
really really long lines uh but anyway
um and eventually i'll put this these
um this code up on my site i just
haven't gotten around to it yet
uh so let's see this one so
all we need to edit here is just we'll
change this to
one day and then we'll come over here
and the only other thing that we need to
change up is that unix timestamp
so what we're going to do is is we can
already see that we've actually
to check the length of the line right we
did that
check here and to check it we split it
up so it's already been split up so we
can do something
there um and then the only other check
was for if values
and that's still the same case here
because we're looking for something with
six
things like if we split this up by comma
this is one
oops one two three four five six seven
so that's okay it's not going to give us
any trouble
the only one that will give us trouble
is this one here so it's one two
three four five six and then we're just
doing a check to see if values is in
there
and if it is we just ignore it so if
value is
not in each line then we do something
right so now what we want to do
is we're going to make some space here
and the variable we need to fix in every
occasion
when you split by comma is going to be
the zero with element or the
you know first element in the array or
the list um so that's the element we
want to change
so we'll come down here and we're going
to say fix me so this will be the fix me
variable
equals split line zero
and then what we're going to do is we
can't do anything yet
because in some of the cases or at least
in one case every poll
split line zero is actually going to be
values right so that's no good but if
it's not value so values isn't in that
line
then what we're going to do is we're
going to make a fixed
variable and that's going to equal
and this is going to be one of those
long lines that if you guys need me to i
can paste it in but just follow along
with me
so fixed is going to equal and what
we're going to use is we're going to do
some
kind of fancy footwork here and we're
going to use a replace function
and in every instance where we find
split line
zero when it's not values we're going to
replace
whatever that is dynamically with
a converted date stamp of that dynamic
thing
so pretty pretty interesting stuff um
just follow along and i'll explain as we
go so fixed is going to be
each line dot replace so each
line so what it's going to do is it's
going to read each of these lines
right here right and then dot replace
what do we want to replace we want to
place uh anything that looks like
fix me so in this case it'll be split
line zero so anything that looks
like the first element in each line so
the unix time stamp
so basically we're dealing with a unix
uh
time stamp so anytime it finds that uh
and we want to replace that
with what and we're gonna replace that
with string
and i believe we have date time let me
make sure i just scroll up real quick
yeah we do have date time and we got
time so we don't need to import anything
else
come back down here so fix me comma
string date time dot date
time and then
from time stamp
and then we want to convert fixed mix
right now fix me
is in uh it's in string form so we need
to convert it to an integer
so fix me just throw that in there
and outside of let's see let me make
sure we're
okay so make sure you got two
parentheses there
uh and then die str
so string from time is what that means
and then now in these parenthesis you
want to specify
um the format that you want it to come
out as so in our case the format that we
want it to come out as
is going to be a percent uppercase y for
a full
year dash percent m so the two digit
little number of the month
dash percent day same thing two digit
number of the day
percent capital h for the hours colon
percent capital
m minutes colon percent uh capital
s for seconds and let us that is our
you should end with three parentheses
i'm going to delete one and add it just
to make sure
it is correct and as long as it
highlights the whole thing like that
you've closed off everything okay
so now that we've done that let me come
down here
and come over and now that we've done
that fixed now instead of stock file
append each line
we want to append fixed so that fixes
that line
now the only other thing that we need to
do i believe
is change the converter here
right so here it's accessing stock file
and it's converting something to that m
dates format strip date to num
and this was the old format remember
that ugly yahoo format
now the new format is very pretty and
sexy so we're just going to copy
this this format above that we just
wrote and paste it
right in there and that will fix that
now it's totally possible we've missed
something or made a typo
but i think that will uh graph our one
day data that we're looking for so let's
go ahead and save it and run it
and see what happens so stock to plot
let's pull up apple
and okay so we got apple it probably
looks like hell for you guys
so you got this right now keep in mind
it's one day data
plotted on and what's happening is we
have a lot higher granularity now
so the width of the width of our
candlesticks
it's too big so let's uh let's go fix
that real quick
um let's see candlestick right here so
right now
we're operating with a .6 width
candlestick let's change that
to let's do it needs to be way smaller
so let's do one
uh zero zero zero five let's try that
that should that should fix it up for us
so
aapl let's see what we got now okay here
we go
much better so just for the record uh it
won't always
or it shouldn't always look like that in
fact let me pull in
let's put i'll add a three day but uh
today is
uh november 4th and the market has only
been open for one hour
so that's why we only have this much
data because one keep in mind the data
is going to be delayed by like 15 to 20
minutes
uh from like real time data but also
it's
it's one minute open high low close and
we've only been open for an hour so
because like right now we've just got
one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve three five fifteen sixteen
like sixteen unless i counted wrong uh
so that's about right the market like i
said the market's been over for an hour
and the data is significantly delayed
usually so
uh keep that in mind um but what what
i'm going to do now
is uh let's let's pull up a three day
since this is actually
we're positive that the chart is working
uh but
just to be sure let me pull up three day
and it might not be one minute open high
low close but it'll be close
i think it'll be five minutes i think is
usually what they do
yeah and this will this will bring us to
another point
okay so this is the three day open hilo
closed data so we can see that it is
indeed working um although you see like
this massive like
nastiness there i did get a comment or
question or request and uh one of my
videos
for how to get rid of uh time series
data
that like get rid of this like straight
line right cause this is market closed
over the entire weekend
so it's pretty bad right so i got a
request for that and
don't worry uh we will be uh showing how
to how to get rid of
that stuff eventually here so um so our
chart is working
and uh just looks kind of crummy right
now so we don't have too much market
data but
we will get there i do want to get to
the next video to show you guys how to
turn this chart now into a live chart
and then i'll make it live and like run
it for a while and speed it up and show
you guys uh the live updates just
because like one minute updates is a
long thing to wait
wait for so anyway um
so that's that that's uh how we how we
can change the chart
obviously we haven't done anything live
but that's how to change the chart
to using more higher granularity data
that's maybe coming through
as a unix timestamp but you can also
use this little conversion method so
like depending on what kind of
information you're you're taking in
uh it's probably in a unix time stamp or
a date stamp
so you know you only really need to
either convert you know down here
or if it's in a unix stamp you can
convert the fix me stuff but
um that this charting application really
should work with any time series data at
all
that's coming in at least open high low
close volume
so uh the next thing that we want to do
then
is i'm going to cut off the video here
and in the next video
we're going to implement the live
updating functionality
to this chart pretty simple edition
there and uh
so that's that so hopefully uh you guys
are all caught up if you have any issues
or something has gone
wrong uh leave a comment below let me
know what's going on
and i'll do my best to help you out
otherwise stay tuned in the next video
as always thanks for watching thanks for
the support the subscriptions
and until next time